let's see if we can use integration by
parts to find the antiderivative of e to
the X cosine of X DX and whenever we
talk about integration by parts we
always say well which of these functions
would we r take a product of two of
these which of these functions e to the
X or cosine of X that if I were to take
its derivative becomes simpler and in
this case neither of them become simpler
and neither of them become dramatically
more complicated when I take its their
antiderivative so here it's kind of a
toss-up which one I assign to f of X and
which one I assign to G prime of X and
actually you can solve this problem
either way so let's just assign this one
let's assign f of X equaling e to the X
and let's assign G prime of X is equal
lling cosine of X so let me write it
down we are saying f of X is equal to e
to the X or f prime of X is equal to e
to the X derivative of e to the X is
just e to the X and we can say that G
we're making the assignment G prime of X
is equal to cosine of X and the
antiderivative that G of X is also or
the antiderivative of cosine of X is
just going to be equal to sine of X
going to be equal to sine of X so now
let's apply integration by parts so this
thing is going to be equal to f of X
times G of X which is equal to e to the
x times sine of X times sine of X minus
minus the antiderivative of F prime of X
F prime of X is e to the X e to the x
times G of X which is once again sine of
X sine of X DX D DX now it doesn't look
like we've made a lot of progress now we
have an indefinite integral that
involves the sine of X so let's see if
we can solve that that let's see if you
can solve this one separately so let's
say if we were trying to find the
antiderivative the antiderivative of e
to the X sine of X DX how could we do
that well similarly we can set f of X is
equal to e e to the X so now this is
we're reassigning although we're
happening to make the exact same
reassignment so we're saying f of X is
equal to e to e to the X f
of x is equal to the derivative of that
which is still e to the X and then we
could say G of X in this case is equal
to sine of X we'll put these assignments
in the back of our brain for now and
then let me make this clear G prime of X
let me whoops
there you go so we have G prime of X G
prime of X is equal to sine of X which
means that its antiderivative is
negative cosine of X derivative of
cosine is negative sine derivative of
negative cosine is positive sine so once
again let's let's let's apply
integration by parts so we have we have
f of X times G of X f of X times G of X
is negative is up with a negative out
front its negative e to the X negative e
to the x times cosine of X times cosine
of X minus minus the antiderivative of f
prime of XG of X F prime of X is e to
the X e to the X and then G of X is
negative cosine of X so I'll put the
cosine of X right over here and then the
negative we can take it out of the
integral sign and so we have we're
subtracting a negative that becomes a
positive and of course we have our we
have our DX right over there and you
might say sound we're not making any
progress this thing right over here we
now expressed in terms of an integral
that was our original integral we've
come back full circle but let's try to
do something interesting let's
substitute back this let's substitute
back this or let me write it this way
let's substitute back this thing this
thing up here up here or actually let me
write it a different way let's
substitute this this for this in our
original and our original equation and
let's see if we got anything interesting
so what we'll get is our original
integral on the left hand side here the
indefinite integral or the
antiderivative of e to the X cosine of X
DX is equal to e
the X sine of X e to the X sine of X
sine of X minus minus all of this
business so let's just subtract all of
this because we're subtracting all of
this so if you subtract negative e to
the X cosine of X it's going to be
positive it's going to be positive
e to the X cosine of X e to the X cosine
of X and then remember we're subtracting
all of this so then we're going to
subtract so then we have minus minus the
antiderivative of e to the X e to the X
cosine of X cosine of X DX DX now this
is integrand just remember all we did is
we took this part right over here we
said we use integration by parts to
figure out that it's the same thing as
this so we substituted this back in when
you subtracted it when you subtracted
this from this we got this business
right over here now what's interesting
here is if we have essentially an
equation where we have our expression
our original expression twice we can
even assign this to a variable and
essentially solve for that variable so
why don't we just add this thing to both
sides of the equation let me make it
clear let's just add the integral of e
to the X cosine of X DX to bat to both
sides e to the X cosine of X DX and what
do you get well on the left hand side
you have 2 times our original integral e
to the X cosine of X DX is equal to all
of this business is equal to this I'll
copy and paste it so copy and paste it's
equal to all of that and then this part
this part right over here cancels out
and now we can solve for our original
expression the antiderivative of e to
the X cosine of X DX we just have to
divide both sides of this essentially an
equation by 2 so if you divide the
left-hand side by 2 you're left with our
original expression the antiderivative
of e to the X cosine of X DX and on the
right hand side you have what it
must be equal to e to the X sine of X
plus e to the X cosine of X over two and
now we want to be careful because this
is an antiderivative of our original
expression but it's not the only one we
always have to remember even though
we've worked hard and we've done we've
used integration by parts twice and
we've had to back substitute in we have
to remember we should still have a
constant here so if you take the
derivative of this business regardless
of what the constant is you will get e
to the X cosine of X and it's actually a
pretty neat looking expression